you tell me how a woman with a penis
down the throat who's gagging how that
is in any way Oh since when did women
exchanging bodily fluids and a little
like bondage become the most obscene
thing in the land we're just not going
to put up with pornographers running the
country any longer when you take people
having sex adults that want to do it
that enjoy what they're doing
how could that be obscene
[Music]
the whole concept of obscenity is up
soon the right to see South Park may
actually depend on the right to watch
but Buster's 3 John staliano has been
indicted on several accounts of
obscenity these are federal charges he
was basically the father of what we call
gonzo which is the really hardcore body
punishing sexing that are now routine in
pornography and he's been charged not
for his own work but he's been charged
for videos and a trailer that his
company has distributed they are all
done by some of the top people in the
industry and these are people that John
chose to do these videos mine being milk
[ __ ] which is the the milk enemas
Joey so Vera's movie which is the
squirting and it was a belladonna
trailer the day after he was indicted
they told me thank you I appreciate what
you did for me and I want to prove to
the world that this this is not obscene
he stands strongly for what he believes
well the material is in many respects
typical of what's available today and
I'd be surprised if they wouldn't get a
conviction I was the chief of the child
exploitation and obscenity section at
the Department of Justice and I ended my
tenure about 17 years ago the United
States Department of Justice enforces
federal obscenity laws which are the
laws against illegal pornography our war
on illegal pornography is against the
pornographers the court has never said
that obscene pornography is protected
speech it's not enough for some people
to say I don't want to have group sex in
a commercial venue and you shouldn't
have the opportunity to do that if you
want to it's not at all what I think is
obscene it's what the Supreme Court says
may be found to be obscene and the
Supreme Court in the case of Miller
versus California 1973 issued a decision
that has a three-part test the first
part of it the two that speak to
communities
standards whether a reasonable person in
the community would find the material to
be appealing to Puran interests or the
second community standard whether a
reasonable person in the community would
find the material to be patently
offensive and then the third which is a
national standard and does the material
have any serious literary artistic
political or scientific value
essentially is hardcore pornography and
the Supreme Court after the three-part
test set out what kind of hardcore
pornography may be found to be obscene
actual or simulated sexual acts whether
it's oral sex of sexual intercourse anal
fetishism graphic sex acts or lewd
exhibition of the genitals regular
intercourse inulin a woman being anally
factually and already penetrated at the
same time even lascivious exhibition of
the genitals of pubic areas a lot of
people don't realize it that could be
prosecuted as obscene we're here to talk
about we were on illegal I don't know no
law we need to basically organize a
movement that says that the
pornographers have hijacked our
sexuality there's hijack to our culture
and our job is to take it back we're
asking Congress to tell the Justice
Department to enforce the laws that
Congress has passed a lot of the
prosecutions have gone after the
low-hanging fruit because they're easy
to win and that's ok you can go after
the low-hanging fruit but I think we
would see a much bigger cleanup if you
will of all this work hard core material
out there if they went after some of the
more higher hanging fruit we've got a
war on illegal pornography we're gonna
win it
it's a war to take away the rights that
people actually have to do things to say
things to feel things that some people
don't think they should have the right
to do I love porn I mean it's Who I am I
mean I still watch porn even if I wasn't
doing this but for me it's it's a way of
life my cardinal rule is it's always
about the girl having fun showing that
she can express herself on camera and
I'm gonna try and make it artistic with
the costumes the set even the sex and
the hacks that we do and that's what I
hope the general public will accept porn
as professional and
and fun people who are afraid of
sexuality they are vigorously pursuing
whatever means they can to regulate
other people's sexuality we go to these
kinds of cultural phenomena to be able
to be shocked to be able to be grossed
out to be able to have our curiosity
satisfied about bodies and organs that
might be different from our own
these videos are meant to gross you out
you know they're meant to make you think
about you know what's acceptable in our
culture and to really challenge those
boundaries about what's acceptable to
you if people want the right to do what
they want to do they have to protect the
rights of other people to do what other
people want to do I don't want the
federal government to take away John's
freedom when I was in charge for about
five years we never lost an obscenity
case because jurors around America
understand what is obscene it's
unbelievable that in the United States
there's actually pictures and words that
you can't sell because the government
decides that it's obscene they have no
right to pornography the culture the
preneur AFER's know exactly what they're
doing and they're not gonna respond to
anything but a stick of the law the
federal government can never take porn
away porn is here and it's gonna stay
when I tried that I discovered that I
liked it you know it put the different
spin on my life some planning to try all
sorts of food all of this sexually
oriented stuff is connected and that's
why if you want to watch South Park you
have to protect the right of somebody
else to watch some porn thing that you
yourself wouldn't dream of looking at
but at least you wouldn't it make
I just want to say that I love these
movies I make them I sell them and that
I'm really glad that some other people
do so that I could have a business that
sells the stuff
[Music]
directed by to my father
[Music]
[Music]